yes I'm I'm working at home today
awesome this is every week right no well
yeah once once a week I get to work from
home which is pretty cool what do you do
actually think people who don't know oh
right so I am GameSpot's community
manager it's awesome
but you also when did you something
worker oh goodness
so I I started not long after Warcraft
launched like in October of that year so
ten years ago I moved out at a very
early age like I moved out of the house
of seventeen so right after high school
um and I didn't get really a whole lot
of opportunities to go out and hang out
with friends no Frank I go potty you go
honey okay I stayed at home and I played
a lot of World of Warcraft and then it
was also at a time in my life where I
was with a guy who was kind of just
yucky like he was he was a little bit
abusive but not like physically so much
but definitely verbally and which is
sort of a picky person in general and
then one day he pushed me down a
staircase so and like at that time I was
like I'm this broke waitress from Texas
and I have no friends outside of World
of Warcraft and I just remember like
going to a friend's house and then
logging in because my friends had heard
over vent they're like what happened and
so I explained and then they're like you
got to get out it's like yeah but like I
didn't have any money so again I was
broke waitress and like all of my
friends and my mom like rallied together
to like get me the plane ticket and
they're like he can crash on our couch
like we'll help find you a job and so I
picked up and I moved back to California
because I was born and raised here so I
was in 2008 cuz I remember it was
Mother's Day 2008
so one of one of the guild mates was was
Vivian's dad and so when I moved out
here like we just happened he was out
here anyway so I was like sure why not
and so like a relationship kind of
quickly forged and then next thing you
know I find out that I'm pregnant and um
which like I was I was excited like I'm
I was like yeah this is a good time for
like I at this point I was on a culinary
career path like I was working towards
become like restaurant management and
stuff like that but it was before like
completely shift anchors I'm going to
GameSpot but so so yeah Vivian was born
in June of 2009 that's crazy that's like
not only do you know did you end up
getting out of tough awful situation
that wouldn't happen unless it was for
your friends in the wrong worker I mean
like I wanna I want to thank that I
would have been smart enough to get out
of it on my own but definitely like
having having guild mates who were there
who were instantly willing to support me
was amazing like I still remember it was
a I was in the Argent hand on our jumped
on and like it was a working group like
it was yeah it was weird
um but it was fun I liked it and it's
yeah
do you ever think you know being a
parent is pretty full-on work with do
you ever kind of remember that if it
wasn't for this video game all the time
he would be sitting here yeah basically
so when I actually when I applied to
GameSpot um in addition to like the
regular application because it was my
first office job and I was like I need
something weird and random to kind of
set me apart and since I love card games
so much I actually made trading cards
for all of the game like my top ten
games and so like it had like a little
bio though GameSpot had given it and
then like why the game was important to
me and so there were games like Mortal
Kombat because like I played that with
my mom or like Smash Brothers because
it's me that's how I really would settle
like who did what chores and then among
them was was World of Warcraft because
without all the Warcraft I probably
would have never had my my daughter and
so and I've told that to Blizzard
folk where they're like that's insane
and I'm like yeah but and she's mine
she's my epic trap I guessing she
doesn't say uh hearthstone all the time
no no got anything like any responsible
parent with a gaming child we do temper
her gaming habits so it's usually like
we do good in school today awesome so we
can we can play some hearthstone or
we'll do like one or two matches or like
on the weekends but like we don't I
don't let her like go to town on on
hearthstone you like playing hearthstone
hey dude is it difficult or are you good
at mm-hmm
are you getting better yeah I feel like
playing any other video games like Mario
yeah which Mario mm-hmm the game and you
see he has brown hair just like me
yeah not the one where he dresses like a
kitty well it's like giddy ha
who's your favorite one the war crime
person you never character
mmm so mom Jana why do you like Jada we
kiss he has like weight hair you like
the cheese magical yeah she needs that
kick you that's a yeah so my mom my mom
played games for my also plays like she
she's a big Skyrim night she also likes
hearthstone because she can play with
Vivian
and so we have we have a
multi-generational hearthstone group it
today and I had a good day it's good
thank you
hey what's your what's your favorite of
all these remember these are my favorite
this one like her this month and rock on
explosion yeah
you
you